so it's the early 1900s and you're one
of the most powerful US senators named
Nelson Aldrich and you and every other
career politician are in a bit of a
pickle a pickle that has plagued
governments since the advent of
government you want more money from the
subjects you will over because I mean do
I even have to explain it obviously you
know how to spend their money better
than they do their money is just better
off in your nobler hands done another
reason why you want more money is for
times of crisis when everyone was too
irresponsible to prepare when everyone
is panicking they'll instinctually look
to you the government for help we need a
lot more action by the federal
government it is almost certain that
Congress will be called upon once again
to provide more relief we need big bold
expensive action from the government now
whether or not you believe that the
government should help them in times of
crisis is irrelevant because if you
don't offer any welfare if you don't
bail them out they'll blame you and
throw you out of office but if you had a
ton of money on your hands however
you'll have the ability to give them
some not welfare and that sounds too
low-class some stimulus yes stimulus
some grants to keep the peace but most
importantly to come off as their saver
the main way to take money from your
subjects is through taxes the problem
with that is that if you tax people too
much they'll go all up in arms and also
throw you off office because who wants
to pay higher taxes so we need a sneaker
way to tax our subjects to extract the
money that we rightfully deserve without
them ever even realizing it enter
printing money if you could print money
you get the same result as taxing more
purchasing power for you the government
to spend and since there's more money in
circulation less purchasing power in the
bank accounts of your plebs except when
you print money since you're not
directly taking money from your servants
and instead decreasing the value of the
money they already have in their bank
accounts that will be too stupid to
catch on while little do they realize
that in the end you end up with the same
amount money you would have gone from
taxes in the first place and leyenda
would less value in their bank accounts
but since the number in their bank
account doesn't change now never catch
on and you're in the clear a much
sneaker and smarter way to tax but now
you've got another
the idea of the government just having
free reign to print as much money as
they want whenever they want just
doesn't sound right
it rubs people the wrong way and
conjures up images of Germans loading up
real barrels of money to buy a loaf of
bread as they should be in that nearly
every society that has freely printed
money in the past eventually collapsed
their currency and fell into economic
turmoil well gee if only there was a way
for you to get all the same benefits of
printing money without tipping off the
public to your scheme enter the Federal
Reserve America's money printer
get two free stocks value up to $1400
for today's video sponsor the free
trading app weeble when you open an
account and deposit at least $100 with
the link below by 1907 other politicians
and bankers alike have tried to create a
money printing machine in the US before
also known as a central bank but all
three attempts failed miserably this
left a sour taste for central banking in
the eyes of the US population
they just didn't really trust them but
something magical happened that year
that would forever changed the course of
history the stock market dropped almost
50 percent people were running to
withdraw their money from banks which
led to a ton of banks and businesses
declaring bankruptcy which later became
known as the panic of 1907 now you being
the very prominent senator Nelson
Aldrich know that it's criminal to ever
let a crisis like this go to waste
people were panicking they lost
confidence in the financial system and
in banks and were demanding that
something just something be done to
prevent this from happening again this
is the perfect opportunity to use this
crisis as an excuse to give the money
printing machine another shot in the US
and reap all the benefits from it so
what do you do on a cold winter night in
1910 you board your private train car
along with a few of your guests to
travel to a luxury vacation spot in
Georgia called Jekyll Island while
telling the public that you know we're
just going on a duck hunt when really
you and your friends are going to plot
out your money printing ambitions
[Music]
you and your five guess and upper
presenting one-fourth of the world 12
the Assistant Secretary of the Treasury
the heads of the most powerful banks of
the time National City Bank of New York
JP Morgan and Kuhn Loeb & Company and of
course you Nelson Aldrich but if the
public caught wind that the heads of
government and big banks were colluding
together to build a central bank they
would never buy it it would never pass
Congress so you had your guests arrive
separately with very specific
instructions to make sure that their
identities and the purpose of your
journey wouldn't leak out to the public
along with the politicians of the time
these big banker friends of yours were
also in a bit of a pickle as a big
banker small banks were popping up all
over the American frontier which meant
that you the big banks in New York we're
losing all of your market shares pesky
competition since you make the bulk of
your money from giving out loans and
collecting interest interest rates at
the time were set pretty reasonably by
the free market not too low not too high
so only serious people took out loans
which meant less profit for you so you
needed a way to lower interest rates at
your whims so more people would borrow
and pay you more interest and lastly to
make more money as a bank you had to be
more risky and lend out more of your
depositors money but as we saw with the
bank runs of the panic of 1907 if you
were too risky you didn't have the
luxury of government bailouts that we
have today so you need something where
you're able to shift your losses onto
the taxpayer to always be bailed out and
it's this common pain point of wanting
to control both banks and the money
supply and I brought the heads of
government and big banks together and
within just a couple years of a fateful
meeting at Jekyll Island the Federal
Reserve System was born shortly after
the bill was signed into law this is
what you had to say before passage of
this act the New York bankers could only
dominate the reserves of New York now
were able to dominate the bank reserves
of the entire country now you have to be
pretty clever to get it to pass Congress
remember the approval of the public is
the key to whatever your heart desires
and to get the public's approval for
your central bank you had to frame it as
in the public's best interest that this
will stabilize the economy that this is
the key to making sure that not
like the terrible crash of 1907 will
ever happen again since Americans
weren't a fan of central banks at the
time you definitely cut it out right
call it a central bank so you needed
something vague hmm the Federal Reserve
that works but even with the deceptive
name it was just one single
government-run bank it will look too
much like a central bank so instead of
one central bank you make it look
decentralized what twelve regional
Federal Reserve banks but then have a
Board of Governors ruling over all the
many ways and then BOOM were just a few
coats of lipstick on the pig America's
third money printing machine is born and
here's how it works
printing money is like a magic trick you
make something out of nothing but you
can't just simply turn on the printing
press and say hey we're gonna print two
trillion dollars today no no no you have
to redirect the public's attention by
calling it something more technical by
making the process more complicated so
that the common man won't be able to
make heads or tails of what you're
talking about call it using the discount
window open market operations changing
the reserve ratio quantitative easing
basically anything that doesn't allude
to hey we're printing money and making
your money less valuable out of all
these different methods the Federal
Reserve uses to control the amount of
money in the money supply open market
operations is by far the most powerful
tool but fair warning this is gonna get
a little convoluted a little confusing
but remember that's the point but if you
stick through this with me I promise you
with that I will turn you into a
money-printing magician and it all
starts with Stubb number one government
debt government is the purpose of this
entire scheme you the government need an
infinite amount of money to spend on
whatever you deem necessary so the
government takes out loans in the form
of Treasury notes or bonds literally a
piece of paper that people pay for that
says the government will pay you back
this loan plus interest in the future as
we're about to see this debt forms the
foundation for nearly all of the
nation's money supply this is also where
the sleight of hand magic comes in what
you the government just did by taking
out these loans was practically create
cash but it doesn't look like it yet
that will come in the next steps thanks
to our shiny new Federal Reserve System
step number two you the government then
sells that Treasury note or a bond to
average citizens this could be big or
small banks that buy these securities
and businesses or ordinary citizens and
when the Fed wants to turn on the
printing press they'll simply buy these
Treasury notes or bonds from the bank's
businesses and people that bought them
but they'll usually only buy from the
major banking firms though but here's
the thing the Fed doesn't have any money
on hand to pay for these Treasuries or
bonds so in return the Fed pays in the
form of new money that's created out of
thin air on the spots since these sales
happen on computers there's usually no
actual new paper money nuts printed only
digits increasing on a computer which
makes our job a lot easier
but it doesn't stop there see banks
don't have to keep all the money you
deposit on hand they can lend out the
majority of your money to collect
interest on being that collecting
interest on loans as the main way banks
make money if they don't lend out the
money you deposit they lose out on all
the potential profits so they're
incentivized to loan out as much of your
money as possible this is called
fractional reserve banking and the Fed
is responsible for sending that fraction
of how much your deposits banks have to
keep on hand which ironically was just
set to 0% so the new money the Fed
created out of thin air from the last
step gets deposited into the banks that
sold the Treasury notes and bonds to the
Fed those banks then lend out that money
as loans to collect interest on that
loan out money will end up in other bank
accounts which will increase the
reserves
of those banks the bank accounts belong
to which will allow those banks to lend
out even more loans and the cycle of
loaned out money ending up in other bank
accounts to be loaned out again repeats
increasing them when you supply which
brings us to the end once you go through
all these convoluted steps the
government took out debt the Fed creates
money for that debt the government spent
that debt and once the money gets
deposited into banks the banks can then
alone out that debt and collect interest
on it once you've gone through all of
that you sir have just accomplished all
the original goals we set after you're
able to print money off then err on
command the modern-day equivalent of
alchemy all this newfound money lowers
the purchasing power of the plebs you
rule over while you the government got
the money that you rightfully deserve or
in other words you just successfully tax
your subjects without them ever even
realizing it now you can use your
newfound money for your stimulus checks
to bail out the big banks to help you
start this whole scheme or whatever your
heart desires so just sit back relax and
enjoy all that sweet manipulated
devalued money it's very money though
that's not real money that's fake money
that's true and I'm sure you're known as
a fake money oh really I know but it's
all based on faith how long is this now
how long is a sustainable though to go
at that pace
but don't enjoy it too much because even
if you print a bunch of money for
yourself the printing won't stop the
genie has been let out of the bottle and
your cash we'll just keep declining and
purchasing power so why not invest all
that hard-earned cash into assets that
appreciate over time instead of losing
value and a great way to start investing
is with a free stock trading app like
weeble that strikes the perfect balance
between ease-of-use and having all the
tools you need they have a clean mobile
app and a very comprehensive web browser
out to make sure that you make the most
out of your newly printed money and for
a limited time weebles giving you 2 free
stocks the first one when you open an
account value between two dollars and 50
cents and 250 dollars and another one
value between 12 dollars all the way up
to $1400 if you deposit at least $100 so
if you like free stuff and not super
advertiser friendly videos like this
claim your two free stocks with the link
below and support the brands that help
make this channel possible Oh guys this
one took a lot more work than usual if
you enjoyed this video essay and you
think other people should see it all I
ask for you to do is just this one small
little thing just go in the comments
below and write I watch them to end to
give the YouTube algorithm a nice boost
I would really appreciate it also the
comments section is getting pretty out
of hand and I love it if you're still
watching this right now you guys are my
biggest supporters I'm talking to you
watching this video in quarantine right
now you guys are my biggest supporters
and I really appreciate it that is all I
have for you guys for this video thank
you so much for watching you've been
awesome